my name is own slithering it and the
chief executive of the Global Reporting
Initiative I've just been moderating the
responsible corporation lunch session a
very interesting session at the dress
the following question growing interest
in environmental social and ethical
risks associated with global business
the how will company face up to the
challenge to turn corporate
responsibility programs into corporate
strategy there was a very very
wide-ranging discussion but first of all
the perfectly of focus and clear
understanding that our economy is
changing needs to change because of
increasing environmental pressures but
also changing social expectations then
companies often intuitively feel that
the time has come that we need to move
forward from a corporate responsibility
program that is kind of in a corner that
is isolated in a company where one
person has a title to deal with this and
that's corporate responsibility needs to
come more into the core of Australia
corporate strategy that we need to
connect finance strategy and
sustainability
the this understanding is through large
extent based on deductive reasoning and
a kind of intuitive understanding NBC a
growing number of leading companies
around Latin America and the world to
pick up this issue and to really prepare
them such the position in an economy
that where economic fundamentals are
going to change where we need other
forms of energy where we need to relate
differently see different relations
between your company and its
stakeholders but when you look into the
shorter and then he also asked will
where is the evidence yes we hear that
consumers expectations are changing and
that is important for financial markets
but in the day-to-day basis with
consumers today
and with with investors that evidence
isn't consistent bill isn't always there
and the point to the complexity of this
is then the interchange will not believe
it will go Stella go Stella step by step
and in order to to get there we need to
really frame the issues more clearly us
discuss the accordance we discussed the
importance of standardization clear
concepts and all including the
information about corporate strategy and
not supporting results in the financial
the social and the economic and
environmental sphere into the corporate
discourse not only is an accountability
exercise but also as a way to
communicate with other companies to
communicate the stakeholders and we
share homes and by making this discourse
more inclusive and making it explicit we
can influence mind changes online frames
and that is probably the most important
conclusion
and of the session that what we are
about is or where we are is we're in the
middle of a massive transformation
process where companies and our economy
need to prepare for a different economy
and where we need to find strategies
that generate green growth not easy but
we need to talk to each other about it
and make the issues explicit